I'm gonna warn you right now this vlog
is awful it is absolute [ __ ] it's
amazing my life has a sense of irony
isn't it the last video I made was all
about asking why do bad things happen to
me in in the time between that video in
this video that's a bad things happened
to me you might be wondering why I'm
standing in front of this incredibly
poor green-screen that's one of the bad
things that happen to me I'll talk about
that in a second but before I just [ __ ]
and moan for like 5 minutes I think it
review of doing a PhD update maybe I
should have it's in theme music last
time I talked about a running code
parallelization to speed up the
efficiency of my program which is
probably gonna sound massively confusing
Jenny one who's new basically I was
trying to speed up this piece of
computer code which I was running apart
my PhD and I successfully done that well
I say successfully I managed to get the
parallelization working but then the
code crashed this weekend which is one
of the other bad things that happen to
me but the important point is the code
paralyzed and parallelized and you know
I actually made manage to do that so
that's a thumbs up I'm now running the
code again and hopefully it will
actually complete this time so yay
in other ph.d news I have been doing a
little bit more theory so I've been
doing some maths after having written up
sure having written up the work that
I've been doing recently I realized
there was a mathematical error in one of
my derivation and so I had to why she
not so much an error just something I
haven't considered so I had to fix that
and that's now been done I've been sort
of doing a little bit of maths on the
side and that's nothing added to my
report and the most significant thing
I've been doing is going back and
reading papers again now I'm a third
year PhD and by this point you might
think that I should have read every
paper on the subject I'm doing right and
the answer that is kind of yes but
mostly no at the start of the PhD here
at Exeter they make you do a literature
review so they asked
all the papers that have anything to do
with your subject and I did that and I
wrote it all up in a big document for
the literature review and that was great
but it's been a while since I've
actually looked at the papers since
because I've just been doing something
that is so completely different from
what's happened before I haven't needed
any literature so I've been working on
my own and consequently I forgot on a
large part of the scientific literature
on the subject so for the past two weeks
what I've been doing is looking through
key papers from the field and basically
read them in detail and writing them up
in a scientific language called lay tech
it's a scientific typesetting language
which makes everything that we do
cordia's it's going to be what I'll
write my thesis in so I've been
converting large sections of these
papers add in my own stuff to it and
then writing out the equations in latex
so that I can hopefully you copy and
paste it into the background chapter on
my thesis which I'd like to get finished
in the next couple of months but back to
the green screen yeah what you're
looking at here is a failure
what is this video you might have seen
on my Twitter or on my Facebook that I
have been trying to shoot this weekend
my crash course series I once it I have
written four other expensive scripts for
crash course in the atmosphere and
stratosphere and I wanted to film it in
front of a green screen and I wanted to
be able to sort of in a very scishow
esque way be able to cut me out of the
background and put me over stuff you
could put equations you can move him
around the frame you know give me lots
of lots of crazy freedom but in order to
do that I would need a green screen and
this is a green screen but it's
unfortunately not a very good one now
part of that is the green screens bolt
because you might see here very large
creases basically if you're shooting on
a green screen creases are the enemy you
you can't have creases because what you
won't get what's called a good key I
took this down I am bit and then found
out no matter what I did I couldn't get
crazy put large iron marks in the feet
where I've melted it so this was a
complete and utter design
I have spent the best part this weekend
constructing the studio with with lights
and sound up here in this green screen
and and everything in the old office is
moving everything around and I am gonna
get precisely no crash course videos out
of it so its complete failure very
quickly for those of you who are
interested this is my setup at the
moment I have two photocell soft boxes
here what are those two key lights I
kind of have a hair light from this but
I don't really have one so it's a two
point lighting setup my audio up here
there is a rode videomic that was
probably deafening and that's on a 3.5
mill
cable extender which is going down here
I don't know it's not it's not on screen
but there's a zoom h4n portable audio
recorder that's recording on there and I
sync it up with my canon 600d in post
and then that's on a boom pole which I
recently got and then this behind me is
a travesty but as I was talking about in
my last video it's not a failure because
I haven't failed to learn from this I
know that I am NOT going to buy a
plastic green screen in the future I am
going to buy a cotton one that if it
comes in creases I can iron and get rid
of them so I'm learn not to make that
mistake I've learned how to this frame
I've learned that the lighting of the
griefing is very important like I'm
trying to use the lights up here as well
as these two soft boxes that I have as
part of my setup and I have learned
technical things about this so I feel
awful at the moment I have had a
terrible terrible weekend trying to get
this to work and finding out that my
bike is broken it's gonna cost 150 quid
to repair and I've got a coal and I just
had to sing in a really long service and
my voice is caning at the moment but you
know yes I think an awful weekend but
I'm learning from this and the next time
I do it will be better
I refuse to consign myself basically to
this weekend being an abject failure I
refuse to let myself fail I have to have
learned something from this or I may as
well not bothered getting out on the
past two days that is not acceptable so
I am you know damn sure I learn from
this although in the meantime like right
now this blog was meant to be very happy
and positive and talking about my PhD
calendar
and all the wonderful work that I've
been getting up to and I have talked
about that but we all have off days we
all have days when things don't go quite
right and today is that for me but I am
NOT going to let it beat me I'm gonna
make damn sure that doesn't beat me as a
result there might be a slight delay in
the crash course videos coming out
because I'm away next weekend in Madrid
but we'll see I'm gonna order in your
green screen we're gonna try again
because I'm not gonna let myself be
bitten by beaten but myself be beaten by
my own tongue by my failures I'm not
gonna let them wear me down and stop me
from doing things I want to do
I'm sorry future Simon for you editing
this because I have no idea how you're
gonna make this mess into a decent video
hopefully the nest video coming out in
this channel will be a crash course
video it might be that I do another vlog
like as a stopgap and for people who are
asking yes I will be doing a day in the
life of PhD student sometime soon not
quite sure yet but it is coming in the
next few weeks and because I don't
require advanced technology for it it
should actually come out when I when I
wanted to thanks for listening to me
whinge and [ __ ] and moan for the past
have many minutes this video turns out
to be and I will see you next time thank
you for watching
and it's completely related to the
program so
thank you again going where are we
how is this a video this is a beer yes
we're at the airport Simon where abouts
gonna run easy get my car
why are we going to stick up now we're
going there for channel 5 this is the
channel car behind me